it's finally here Nigeria's much awaited
election
people are gathering to cast their vote
but the polling stations are late
this one in Lagos opened just in time
for former State Governor and
presidential candidate Bola ahmatinobu
to cast his vote he
other front-runners former vice
president and people Democratic Party
candidate atiku abubakar and a wild card
61 year old former Banker Peter Obi who
has been galvanizing the country's youth
whoever does win has a mammoth task
ahead sir how do you expect to solve the
country's economic crisis
be a transformative government
to change the economic crisis it's not
that we have as a challenge
Nigeria is also dealing with a
widespread security crisis as well as
endemic corruption and soaring
unemployment making this the most
consequential election in the country's
history the future of Nigeria at stake
we've got to get it right this time
we've done so many years of
blunders I would say and hopefully this
time will get it right do you think that
the candidates are able to bring about
change in the country
some of the country
candies whether we will want to elect
them
we met presidential hopeful tinubu again
this time at his home Mr tinubu there
are millions of Nigerians who've left
the country for a better life in
countries like the UK and many young
people who want to leave how can you
make this country better for them so
that more young people feel like they
can make a life here
they will stay at home if you can create
job opportunities for them they will
stay at home
but many young people here don't trust
the political promises or the process
ATM and I'm going to be on today we
announce the results before I leave it's
why are you staying so long you've
caused your vote why don't you leave
because I want to watch
so that I know that um
my vote counts I know I want to see I
want to see my vote count
the tightest race Nigeria has ever seen
and now the votes have been cast they
watch and wait
Sky News Lagos